let me ask you a ridiculous question
who's the greatest of all time freestyle
or folk style oh wrestling wrestling hmm
well i i will say my knowledge past like
the year 2000 is really
not that great because you can which
direction sorry after 2000 no before
because you can't find any film or
anything you know and so you hear of all
so you need evidence you need direct
evidence i want to be able to watch them
and see them and feel the times and feel
their opponents and you know all those
things to really like i i hate giving
bad answers you know so um i would
i there's just not enough footage of any
of those people you know we took we go
back to someone like alexander medved
like you can't find footage you can't
find anything on him you know it's like
who is he wrestling i you know i'm not
sure so um
post 2000 i think and obviously just
freestyle so
um americans right let's just say tf has
the probably the best argument posted i
think said july of um if you have the
russian tank that guys yeah so who's
who's better snyder said you're alive so
sigil i just wanted the olympics i
understand this i understand how that
works but there's pretty close right
not really not not that much but in
general the match up so well so kyle won
the first one in 17. said joel i have
pinned him the following year but then
kyle lost and took bronze in 19
um and then just lost i don't i don't
want to say fairly decisively but it was
it was six to three and the there was a
late take down he kind of gave it up and
maybe
feels really competitive maybe he
wouldn't have um
they're gonna wrestle again in like two
weeks here so
that you know yeah you i mean you have
to say central live at this point
there's nothing else to say unless kyle
proves us otherwise
yeah
not enough people talk about said you
live okay why
you think that guy should go to mma i
think kyle should go to mma some of
these guys yeah they're making enough
money wrestling where they don't really
feel the need to it's just terrifying
though as a heavyweight such a life
would probably it's like
it's like could be but heavyweight well
i don't know if you remember do you
remember bill mahoff
so below mockoff actually was the
russian representative in both styles of
2016 grappling freestyle um
and he was to my knowledge the only
person the ufc's ever signed that was
zero and z in modern era signed that was
zero and zero and then he actually never
ended up fighting
but weird right so yeah motivation
i don't know i don't know what the story
is sometimes out of russia i mean maybe
you have better sources than i do
sometimes it feels like dudes just
disappear like they're a world champ or
a little bit champ and they'll say
you're like wait
where'd he go you talked [ __ ] about
russia earlier in the conversation so
what'd i say i i forgot but i think
steroids i think somebody's going to
show up to your door i'm worried i
honestly i've said enough bad things
where i would be you know kind of
looking over my shoulder if i went
uh i for one love the russians what
about icarus
how does that make you feel what about
it it's fake news oh really i'm just
kidding it's probably maybe it is i
don't know i don't know yeah you know
it's troublesome and i hate cheating in
all of its forms
you